it's summertime on campus my favorite
time because no one is here
undergrads are on a break and I can move
around campus unimpeded amu is huge
canvas so instead of owning a car and
trying to find a park I get around on my
electric bike first stop is the physics
building where my office is this is the
ion accelerator and these are tanks of
liquid nitrogen and helium which people
use to cool down their experiments this
week I've been helping my supervisor to
put together a grant proposal for a new
piece of equipment essentially an
upgrade to an existing microscope so
that we can apply forces to cells and
see how they respond and stiffen under
that pressure as a way to protect
themselves that is essentially what I do
i poke plants to see how they defend
themselves from pathogen attack so I
sent some emails did some paperwork and
also read some papers in one of my last
videos I said that one of my resolutions
was to read a lot more here I'm using
min delay to keep track of papers I find
interesting the really relevant stuff I
will print out and go through at
lunchtime I went to a dance class at the
gym which I really love and since it's
close to the biology building I then
popped over to gross and seeds
these are seeds I have prepared earlier
but I need to move them to a constant
temperature room for five days so that
they can grow these are some from a
while ago that I never used and need to
throw out
I set the seeds up right so they grow
flat towards the overhead light source
the plants are genetically modified to
flourish with jellyfish DNA so these are
off to the Hazzard bin since my
background is in physics and not biology
I also went to the library to get out
some things that might help me the Uni
is a bit of a construction zone at the
moment they have demolished the main
student area and are currently building
a new one in the meantime they have lots
of food trucks on campus having done my
undergrad degree in post earthquake
Christchurch I am no stranger to
construction zones and pop-up spaces the
rest of campus is pretty nice there are
plenty of wholesome critters around in
the evening I went to a talk by Duncan
Haldane who shared the 2016 Nobel Prize
in Physics for his work on topological
matter
he is visiting from Princeton and gave a
talk about how topological properties
such as how many holes a material has do
apply to materials at the quantum scale
it's really cool stuff
of course I then put this video together
for you I hope it gave a bit of insight
into my life as a grad student thanks
for watching and I'll see you next time